-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
you know from shows like
"Big Little Lies"
and "Parks and Recreation,"
as well as the film
"Step Brothers."
He stars in the fantastic
series "Severance,"
which is streaming
on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-So what is my job?
-Are you really asking me that?
-Yeah.
What is it we actually do here?
-We serve Kier, you child!
And until you get that through
your mildewed little brain
and hit quota,
MDR's hallway privileges
are hereby revoked.
So get your little ass
back to your desk
and stay there
until you're told to move!
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Adam Scott,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
So happy to have you here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-I've got a million questions
about "Severance,"
but I want to start --
you posted this photo yest--
Father's Day.
Happy Father's Day.
-Thank you very much.
-Father of two.
-Thank you.
-You've got a couple
of teenagers.
-A couple teenagers.
-And you posted this photo, and
it looks like -- What is that?
Like a box with a towel over it?
-Yeah, it's a last-minute
Father's Day gift,
as Father's Day gifts
tend to be,
with a towel thrown over it
rather than wrapping paper.
-Gotcha.
So they obviously knew that
you would immediately clock
they put very little thought
into the wrapping.
-Absolutely.
And they don't care.
Because Father's Day
is kind of a joke.
-It's kind of a joke.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-Like, Mother's Day
is, like, the whole country
shuts down for a week.
-Right.
-Rightly so.
-Rightfully so, exactly.
-And dads are just dads.
-Yeah.
-So we're fine.
-I basically --
When my wife said,
"What do you want
on Father's Day?"
And I'm like, "I want to do
what I do every Sunday,
but I want you to not be mad."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
That's great. That's great.
-Just, like, a day where, like,
I'm gonna do all the same stuff
but no side eye.
-That's right. Oh, man.
-What was under the towel?
-Spikeball, the game,
which we already have.
-Okay.
-Which is fine.
-Yeah.
-My son did -- He coded me
a computer program
that he made just for me.
-Okay, so that,
obviously, that means --
I mean, I'm impressed
that a kid can do that.
-Yeah. Impressive.
And it was like -- He had me
sit down at his computer,
and it kind of asks like
three or four rudimentary
kind of simple questions.
But after a few questions, no
matter what answers I typed in,
it always just said,
"Adam is a penis."
[ Laughter ]
Which, frankly
made me even prouder.
-Yeah. Yeah.
It makes me less proud of him
as a coder,
but the sense of humor,
it's like --
Yeah, the two are kind of
meeting in the middle.
-Absolutely.
-Your daughter, does she
also enjoy teasing you,
giving you a hard time?
-She does.
She's always trying to find
new ways to insult me.
The other day, I went into --
I was walking through
the living room,
and she was in there
on her laptop.
And I was just like, "Hey,
honey, what are you up to?"
And she's like, "Nothing."
So I was like, "Okay, well,
I have to look at your computer
and see what you're looking at."
And no joke, she had just
googled "sick burns for actors."
[ Laughter ]
And you know what?
It wasn't even Father's Day.
-Yeah, that's very sweet
that she was thinking
about you on non-Father's Day.
-That's right.
-So, we've spoken
in the past about --
And obviously they were younger.
It's been a while
since we talked about this,
but they did not enjoy
watching "Parks and Rec."
They did not like seeing you
in that,
even though
that is a show that --
I have heard from friends
of mine, kids love that show.
They love that
it's about friends
and it has
a very family atmosphere.
But they did not ever
come around.
-Never watched it.
-There was something about me
being in it
that ruined it for them
preemptively.
They love "The Office"
and all the other shows
sort of around --
-In that universe, right.
But now, "Severance."
-Yeah.
-Are they watching it?
-Yeah, and they love it.
-That's great.
What do you think is
the difference that tipped it
towards being able to suffer
through their dad on screen?
-I don't know, because I feel
like I am on the verge
of ruining it for them
by being present inside of it.
But I don't know.
Something about the kind of
mystery puzzle box of it.
And their friends are into it,
which I think is
part of why they like it.
But I love that
they actually watch it.
-Do you feel like you have to,
like, cloak a little bit
how psyched you are
that they're watching it?
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Because if you overdid it,
they would just tune right out.
-Oh, my God.
If I burst into tears
by the fact that they're
acknowledging my career,
then they would
run away from it.
-It also seems
a little dangerous
that their friends
like it, as well,
because you could not
just blow it for them,
but for their entire
social group.
-I know. I even got a text
from one of my son's friends
just complimenting me
on the show,
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
This is like -- Oh, my God.
This is a huge step."
-That's really -- I just like
that he liked it so much
that he said to your son,
"Can I get your dad's number?"
-Yeah. I know. I know, I know.
I had bragging rights
for a couple weeks.
-That's allowed. That's only
allowed to work that way.
-That's right.
-You can't say like,
"Can I get your friends'..."
-Nope. Nope.
That wouldn't go over well,
for some reason.
-I actually -- So,
a friend of mine, he had a kid
in the Little League
World Series.
He hit, like,
a walk-off home run,
and I said to my friend -- This
is a high-school friend of mine.
-Yeah.
-And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
That's so great."
And he was like, "Could you
make a video for the team?"
I'm like, "sure."
He goes, "Great.
I'll give you his number."
I'm like,
"I'm not sending it to him."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-"I'll send it to you,
and then you show him."
-Needs to be a go-between.
-Yeah.
-"Texting Videos to Teens
with Seth," yeah.
-Anything that starts with
"I can explain!"
-Yeah, yeah.
"Don't worry about it."
-"It's about baseball."
Alright.
I have a ton of questions
about "Severance,"
which we're going to get to.
We'll be right back with more
from Adam Scott.